Merhaba bugünkü konumuz simple present
tense yani namu diğer geniş zaman
İngilizcedeki zamanların içinde en çok
kuralları olan ve anlaşılması en zor
olan zaman bu Bu yüzden bu dersi çok
dikkatli dinlemeniz gerekiyor
gerektiğinde de videoyu durdurarak
notlar almak
isteyebilirsiniz geniş zaman yapar eder
gider gelir şeklinde cümleler kurduğumuz
zaman Öncelikle cümle yapısı üzerinde
duralım ardından kullanım yerlerine
bakalım ilk olarak olumlu cümleyle
başlıyorum Her zamanki gibi özneyle
başlayacağım özneleri yine tekil ve
çoğul olarak ikiye ayırıyorum şimdiki
zamanda ne tekillere ne de çoğullara
giren ay öznesinin burada çoğullara
dahil edildiğine dikkat edin 16 videoda
hevgat hezgat konusunu anlatırken de
böyle olmuştu mantığa ters gelse de bunu
böyle öğrenmemiz gerekiyor özneden hemen
sonra fiilimi
getiriyoruz şimdiki zamanda fiille
öznenin arasında is are yardımcı
fiillerini kullanıyorduk burad ise
doğrudan fiili getiriyoruz öğrencilerin
yaptığı tipik bir hata geniş zamanda da
bu araya geniş zamanın yardımcı fiilleri
olan do ve does sözcüklerinden birini
getirmek oluyor Aslında bu da yanlış
olmasa da cümleye farklı bir Anlam
katıyor ki onu birazdan anlatacağım
fiiller imiz
gelsin İngilizcedeki s takılarından
bıkmış olduğunuzu biliyorum Ama merak
etmeyin bunu da öğrendikten sonra geriye
Başka bir S kalmayacak geniş zamanda
sadece olumlu cümlede fiile eklenen bu s
takısı yalnızca özne tekil olduğu
durumlarda geliyor yani çoğul öznelerden
sonra veya olumsuz cümlede ya da soru
cümlelerinde bu s takısını göremezsiniz
s takısı Bu kadar nazlı olduğu için
öğrenciler de s getirmeyi sıklıkla
unutabiliyor 18 derste nesnelerin sonuna
gelip çoğul anlamı katan s takısının
Bazı özel durumlarını öğrenmiştik Hani
Kelimenin sonu s ile bitiyorsa s
takısını Es şeklinde getirmek gibi işte
tüm Bu kurallar geniş zaman s takısı
için de geçerli Bu yüzden bunları tekrar
anlatmıyorum cümlelerimiz buraya kadar
anlamları O siler o yıkar o yer ben
bilirim sen içersin Biz oynarız onlar
dans eder şeklinde oldu şimdi ne yiyip
ne içtiklerini belirtmek için yanlarına
birer nesne koyalım cleans house was
hersan Hocam son cümle
koymadınız koymadım Çünkü her fiil
geçişli değildir yani nesne
almaz sonra yine isteğe bağlı olarak bir
yer zarfı
ekleyebiliriz yine isteğe bağlı olarak
zaman zarfı ekleyebiliriz Tabii geniş
zamanda eylemlerin tekrar edilme
durumları söz konusu olduğu için geniş
zamana uygun bir zaman zarfı getiriyoruz
Örneğin O şu anda yüzünü yıkar
cümlesinde olduğu gibi geneli değil de o
anı anlatan bir zaman zarfını geniş
zaman
Peki neleri kullanmak kulağa hoş geliyor
bakalım ile başlayan her şey geniş
zamana yakışıyor Sabahları Akşamları
dediğimizde ise tekrar edilme durumu söz
konusu olduğu için sıkıntı
yok şimdi cümlelerimizi sold Sağ
O her hafta garajında arabasını
yıkar O her ay bir muz yer know the
answer All the time Ben cevabı her zaman
bilirim drink lon in The Garden in even
sen akşamları bahçede limonata
içersin scho Once a Biz okulda haftada
bir defa futbol oynarız Dance the
Pr Onlar yılda bir kere mezuniyet
balosunda dans ederler
geniş zamanda tüm zaman zarfları
cümlenin sonuna gelmiyor a yok artık hiç
hoş değil bir grup zaman zarfı fiilden
hemen önce geliyor şimdi Bunlara
bakalım always usually frequently often
s
rarely gibi zaman zarflarının yerleri
cümlenin sonu veya fiilin önü diye
öğretilmeli cümle başında da
kullanılabiliyor bu tür cümleleri hatalı
olarak kabul etmemek lazım özellikle
sometimes kelimesi ü pozisyonda da
rahatlıkla kullanılabiliyor He sometimes
cleans The House sometimes He cleans The
House He cleans The House sometimes gibi
fiilden önce gelen bu zaman zarflarının
içine asla veya hiç anlamlarına gelen
Never sözcüğünü de katabiliriz tabii
Never kullandığımızda cümle olumludan
olumsuza kayacağı unutmamak lazım örnek
verelim He Never cleans The House O asla
evi
temizlemez Şimdi bir de olumsuz cümle
yapısına bakalım olumsuz cümlede geniş
zamanın yardımcı fiilleri olan do ve
does devreye giriyor ama tabii tek
başlarına değil yanlarına olumsuzluk
anlamı katan not kelimesini alıyorlar ve
genellikle kısaltılarak doesn't Don't
şeklinde yazılıp
okunuyor Peki ufak bir tadilat daha
yapmamız gerekiyor
mu yo iyi böyle s takısı sadece olumlu
cümlede gelir demiştik s takıları
gitsin soru cümlesinde de her zaman
olduğu gibi yardımcı fiiller imiz
özneyle yer değiştirerek cümlenin başına
geliyor bu sorulara kısaca Yes She does
no She Doesn't Yes they do no They Don't
şeklinde kısa yanıtlar
verebilirsiniz gitmez misin yapmaz mısın
şeklinde olumsuz soru cümlesi yapmak
istersek de cümleye doesn't ve Don't la
başlayabiliriz
w h kelimeleriyle soru yapmak istersek
de bu kelimeleri yine soru cümlesi
yapısının en başına
getiriyoruz dersin başında olumlu
cümlede Yardımcı fiil
kullanılabildiği olacağından
bahsetmiştim Şimdi bunu açıklayayım
tabloda gördüğünüz şekilde kullanımları
vurgu yapmak istediğimizde tercih
ediyoruz ve cümleyi okurken do do
kelimelerini Üzerine basa basa okuyoruz
Örneğin birine seni seviyorum dediniz
ama size inanmadı Siz de onu gerçekten
sevdiğinizi vurgulamak için şöyle
diyebilirsiniz I do love
you bu tür bir kullanımda cümle olumlu
olmasına rağmen fiilin sonuna EST takısı
getirmediğimiz de dikkat
edin cümle yapısını anladıysak Şimdi de
geniş zamanın nerelerde kullanıldığına
bakalım bu kısmı anlamak Önemli çünkü
geniş zaman İngilizcede Türkçedeki gibi
kullanılmıyor Örneğin Ben Ankara'da
yaşıyorum cümlesini Biz Türkçede şimdiki
zaman yapısında söylüyoruz ancak
İngilizcede bu cümle için geniş zaman
kullanmak zorundayız bunun sebebi şu
İngilizcede şimdiki zaman gerçekten de
konuşma anında olan olayları anlatmak
için kullanılıyor geniş zaman ise o anda
olan olayları değil de daha geniş bir
zamana yayılan genel durumları
anlatmakta kullanıyor mesela Tom speaks
German cümlesinden Ben Tom'un Almanca
bildiği sonucunu
çıkarıyorum Tom is
cümlesinden Tom'un o anda Almanca
konuşuyor olduğunu
anlıyorum geniş zaman cümle yapısını
hikaye ve romanlarda da sıkça görüyoruz
olayları anlatmak için şimdiki zaman ve
geçmiş zamandan ziyade geniş zaman
kullanılıyor zaten Türkçede de böyle
değil mi İçeri girer kapıyı usulca
kapatır ve ana annesini yatakta uzanmış
vaziyette
görür 16 derste anlattığım hevgat hezgat
yapısını genellikle İngilizlerin tercih
ettiğini söylemi
Amerikalılar bu Yapı için geniş zamanı
tercih ediyor ve sahip olmak anlamına
gelen have fiiline tıpkı normal bir fiil
gibi muamele ediyorlar dikkat ettiyseniz
have fiili dedim Has demedim çünkü Bu
fiilin Aslı have ve has kelimesi ise
sadece hein s takısı almış hali yok
artık hiç hoş
değil şeklinde okumak kulağa hoş
gelmediğinden böyle bir şey yapmış
olsalar gerek birkaç örnek cümle kuralım
Onun bir köpeği var She has a dog Onun
bir köpeği yok She Doesn't have a dog
Onun bir köpeği var mı does She have a
dog aynı cümleleri İngiliz kullanımıyla
yapsaydık şöyle olurdu She has got a dog
She hasn't got a dog Has She got a
dog Evet bu konuyla ilgili olarak tüm
Söyleyeceklerim Bunlar şimdi bu derste
öğrendiklerimizin kullanıldığı film
alıntılarım gelecek ardından da çeviri
ile öğren kitabımdan konuyla ilgili
alıştırmalar çözeceğiz kitabı satın
almak veya bu dersin yazılı şeklini PDF
dosyası olarak indirmek için konu
anlatımı ncom siteme
gidebilirsiniz kendi Elinizde bir özel
ders öğretmeni arıyorsanız da
özelderscom sitesine bakabilirsiniz
şimdi film alıntılarım gelsin
[Müzik]
round if i'm
Wrong i
[Müzik]
Win i Just have
fei Victor maynard you know him you know
where He is no no one knows him no one
ever sees him not even his clients old
school so How come you know what He
looks
like Rum
Oh i Feel safe With You You're Wise and
[Müzik]
şimdi öğrendiğimiz Bu konuyla ilgili
alıştırmalar çözeceğiz bunun için çeviri
ile öğreni kullanacağız sizden Türkçe
cümleleri İngilizceye çevirmeni
isteyeceğim Biraz sonra cümleleri
ekranda gördüğünüz zaman videoyu
durdurun ve kendinize 5 dakika kadar
süre tanıyın Hazırsanız başlayalım
[Müzik]
Sabahları dişlerimi fırçalarım cümlesi
olumlu cümleye örnek ve zaman zarfını
cümlenin sonuna getireceğim
Brush Ay kelimesinin geniş zamanda çoğul
kabul edildiğini bu yüzden fiilin sonuna
s takısı getirmediğim dikkat edin her
gün saat 6'da eve gelmem olumsuz bir
cümle örnek Don't Come Home
at dersler her zaman saat 99'da mı
başlar bir soru cümlesi do classes
always Start at n dersler yani öznem
olan dersler kelimesi çoğul olduğu için
do ile başladığım dikkat edin asla
futbol oynamayız We Never play football
Never kelimesi zaten halihazırda
olumsuzluk anlamı kattığı için olumlu
cümle yapısıyla söyleniyor Bu yüzden bu
şekilde yaptım
Steven okuldan sonra kod pantolon Giyer
yine olumlu cümleye bir örnek Steven
wears Jeans after
school Umarım burada kod pantolon için
Code demediniz bu tür alıştırmalar
hoşunuza gittiyse devamını çeviriyle
öğren kitabımda bulabilirsiniz tanıtım
ve satis sayfasına gitmek için sağ üst
köşedeki i harfine tıklayabilirsiniz
Ayrıca bu kanala ekleyeceğim yeni
videolardan haberdar olmak için sol üst
köşeye tıklayarak kanalıma abone
olabilirsiniz izlediğiniz için teşekkür
ederim Bir sonraki videoda görüşmek
üzere hoşça kalın
[Müzik]